the sandy soil of the suffolk brecklens
is perfect for root crops like potatoes
and carrots and onions these potatoes
destined for one of britain's high-end
supermarkets
the irrigation required especially on
this soil is almost mind-boggling this
summer the houston estate is using 22
million gallons of water every week
that's enough to fill more than 40
olympic sized swimming pools it's
unprecedented i'm incredibly worried
just not only myself but number of
farmers in certainly in this area in
east anglia that haven't seen conditions
such as this ever before in their you
know their careers the danger that
people have run out of water to irrigate
their crops
is real
this is one of the estate's two
reservoirs when it's full it holds 80
million gallons of water in practical
terms it's currently empty the last few
centimeters of water too shallow to be
pumped out the head of the uk
environment agency is warning that the
gap between the increased demand for
water and the availability of it is
closing fast it's a scenario he's
described as the jaws of death and
without urgent action the crossing point
at which demand exceeds availability is
just 20 years away
july's record heat wave has now abated
but the long-term prognosis is alarming
official data projects that by 2050 some
of britain's most vulnerable rivers
could have up to 80 percent less water
and summer temperatures might be more
than seven degrees hotter than now we
know what climate change is likely to
bring to this country we also know we've
got a growing population we've got
demographic change which collectively uh
resulting in more demand for water we
can put in place mechanisms to manage
those pressures the sooner we do it the
easier it will be to push those jaws of
death back but if we don't take action
they're definitely coming
mechanisms such as fitting thousands
more domestic water meters and putting
water efficiency ratings on household
appliances the national farmers union
wants water to be regarded as a uk
strategic asset so it might be that
there's a lot of waterfalls in the east
that has to be pumped into the some of
the reservoirs in the in the west you
know it's it's it's the ability to do so
to think on a be light on our feet to
move water around to the best effect
to make sure that we've got enough
strategic supplies to meet all of our
demands as we move forward
when it comes to the impact of water
scarcity the uk's farmers are like the
canary in the coal mine and when they
are as worried as they are now it's a
signal that the whole country needs to
be concerned
let's bring in paul brennan now who is
in suffolk in eastern england paul
there's been some developments today
with the announcement of the first hose
pipe bands meaning no more water in your
garden
that's correct i mean my report there
spoke about the pressure and challenges
that the farming community are facing
particularly arable farmers and i'm
standing in that reservoir that i
mentioned in my report you can see that
if i was standing here when the when
this reservoir was full the water
surface would be some nine meters above
my head and instead it's barely 20
centimeters deep um but these are now
also problems that are impacting
household domestic water consumers as
well
and today in the southern areas it's
southern water is the company
responsible the areas of hampshire and
isle of wight uh people there about two
and a half million customers there are
going to be banned from using their hose
pipes or sprinklers in the garden from
1600 gmt this afternoon another company
south eastern water will from next
friday
ban people in kent and sussex from using
hose pipes in those areas so more than a
million people uh impacted there it's
important to say though that those are
really almost sticking plaster solutions
to what is a much deeper structural
problem with water supply it's important
also to state that on average rainfall
in the uk has been pretty stable over
recent decades it's averaging nationally
at around 1100 millimeters a year
but it's unevenly distributed there is a
lot more rain falling in the north and
west a lot less in the south and the
east it's falling a lot more during the
winter and we're seeing a lot drier
summers so the challenge that the
planners and those people responsible
for long-term planning are having to
tackle is how to
even out that uh that demand even out
the the pro the provision uh build and
invest in more reservoirs um host pipe
bands yeah it's short-term solutions but
it really needs long-term solutions to
tackle this indeed thank you very much
for breaking all down for us paul
brennan in eastern england